well these magical dreams are very old
you know i mean i do think we want to
we want to uh
walk
the golden streets of the imagination
either we want it as heaven
or we want it as a buddhist
visualization of some mandalic realm or
we want to return to the high days of
atlantis or we and virtual reality can
deliver
you know it can actually release you
into literary narrative
as though it were real
and
you know i think very quickly
we may the the real struggle in greg
against fiction he makes clear that and
i agree with him that the real struggle
that we will face in the future is the
struggle to remain uh
sensible to each other
that there is going to be a tendency for
us like the head of a dandelion to just
explode
in a million directions
everyone their own private idaho
everyone uh completely able to project
their own
fears hopes dreams phobias obsessions
with such crystalline hard-edged
perfection and persuasive realism that
the real struggle will be to remain
coherent for the word human
to include us all
and not exclude anyone we don't want to
divide into
those who till the earth those who went
in machine bodies to the stars and those
who downloaded themselves into nano
viruses and disappeared over the edge of
the event horizon into the black hole at
the center of the galaxy i mean
maybe we want these things i like the
idea of the human family
whatever its individual
expressions and admirations staying
with a coherent image i mean of course
we're all different but our commonality
is in the bedrock of this planet
uh
something not likely to be given up by
the thing
and maybe unity is not the way to go
well this this i don't have an answer
here this was the issue that hovered
over diaspora the
greg egan's novel that set the most far
in the future because
at least three forms of human beings had
come into existence so diametrically
different from each other that they
operated basically in complete
isolation from each other i mean
some people became cyborgs
human machine unions that were
essentially immortal and that could
cruise the stars and
have you know cosmic adventures and then
but what most people did was they became
entirely digital
they had no
interface to hardware they simply became
streams of electrons
living out endlessly and embraed
fantasies in
the synthetic realities and then the
then there was the predictable third
group the earth-centered purists who
tilled the soil and
had dirt under their fingernails and
actually had sex to procreate rather
than
dial up things out of vats and stuff
like that
and then
but
yeah i mean people will choose whatever
they want and of course people will
migrate between one group and another
the one thing that all this makes me
feel good about is i think it it
it's an expansion of choice
and then you know presuming there's some
kind of
overarching dynamic whether darwinian or
something else it will all titrate out
in whatever direction it wants to go
one fantasy i've had is that what man
could do for the earth is make
everything conscious
you know that grateful dead song you are
the eyes of the world
you know let every eye lead to a
conscious mind let the squirrel think
and the squid thing can the bumblebee
think
because for sure you know we will
artificially create robots and milocrans
for ourselves to pass among
into the natural world as uh inhabitants
of animal bodies but why not just bring
all
animal mind to the threshold of
sanctions
could that be done well we don't know
because we don't know
upon what
foundation sentience rests whether it
requires a certain
number of cc's of brain mass or whether
that's a completely preposterous and
absurd notion and that conceivably
a paramecium or a housefly or a
hummingbird could have
a kind of shared intelligence when
everything has its own intelligence
anyway that's the expression of its
nature but imagine a com planet-wide
community of seamless
intelligence where you know you could
log on to the mind of coral reef as
easily as you could log on to the
internet
[Music]
you